Oh surrender
Mass Effect Andromeda comes out in less
than a month and I'm a bit worried as
someone who's played through the entire
series multiple times and delve deep
into the lore this franchise means a lot
to me and if you're watching this video
chances are you feel the same way after
four hours of hands-on time with a
preview build of Mass Effect Andromeda
there's a lot I enjoyed but I also
noticed some red flags unfortunately we
were not allowed to record our play
session so what you'll be seeing is
older footage but make sure to subscribe
so when we do finally get some more
you'll be the first to see it my demo
started from the very beginning of the
game which opens with writer your player
created character waking up from 600
years of cryo sleep writers aboard the
Ark Hyperion a vessel carrying thousands
of human colonists to Andromeda but the
spacecraft now finds itself trapped in
an inky substance called the scourge
forcing part of the crew to touch down
on the nearest planet following a
harrowing descent that separated writer
from most of his crew I was able to
start playing though controlling Rider
felt pretty good from the get-go
movement really began to shine once I
reached my first combat encounter
it's clear Mass Effect Andromeda is
taking a much more kinetic and
fast-paced approach to the combat rather
than hugging cover I was using my jet
pack to zip around the battlefield if an
enemy was hiding I jumped jet in the air
hover and rain fire from above and if I
found myself pinned or taking too much
damage I could jet away you can still
play Andromeda like a cover shooter but
both the new and old abilities fit
perfectly with the sped up pace and
after flipping through the extensive
skill trees in an in-depth upgrade
system it's clear that Mass Effect
Andromeda will foster a huge number of
play styles
it was also comforting to see how much
in drama des has embraced mass effect
RPG routes Andromeda may look like an
action driven third-person shooter but
there's a lot more going on under the
hood there's a deep leveling system
plenty of customization and a crafting
component the class system from previous
Mass Effect games has been removed and
replaced with profiles you can tailor
and swap on-the-fly even if you picked
an adept profile at the beginning you
can unlock abilities from any of the
different trees as you explore Andromeda
you will also come across plenty of loot
like armor pieces weapon modifications
and supplies like specialty ammo most of
the loot is found in boxes similar to
Mass Effect one and the resources can be
located by diligently scanning wildlife
flora and architecture when you return
to your spacefaring base of operations
The Tempest you can use your resources
and supplies to research new weapons and
armors once you've successfully
researched an item you can construct it
assuming you have the necessary amount
of crafting materials I only spent about
20 minutes looking through the R&D menus
but the number of options are staggering
once you've crafted your perfect weapon
or set of armor you can even name it
on paper Mass Effect Andromeda is
heading in the right direction
exploration is back the combat has been
improved and it's very much an RPG so
then why am I worried for one the game
lacks polish typically when we play an
early build of a game we expect to see
glitches infinite loading screens
texture pop-in and so on in many cases
these kinks are worked out in time for
full release
but andromeda comes out in less than a
month which obviously doesn't leave much
time to address the rough edges I
noticed some cutscenes were missing
sound the lip-syncing was off at times
the frame rate would drop and some NPCs
were missing detail and textures this
was an older less complete build but I'm
nervous Mass Effect Andromeda will
launch with its fair share of technical
issues I'm also worried that Andromeda
won't have the same wow factor that Mass
Effect 1 & 2 had both of those games
broke new ground they set a new standard
for cinematic RPGs the famous dialogue
system has since been adapted and
amended by many developers over the past
few years from what I played Andromeda
appeared to be treading unfamiliar
ground the lush open environments looked
impressive and driving the Nomad felt
fantastic but based on what I saw
Andromeda seems like it improved Dragon
Age Inquisition which isn't a bad thing
but is it what I really want out of a
Mass Effect game I don't think so
on the other hand though I do trust
Bioware so yes I'm a bit worried but one
thing is for sure the combat and RPG
elements are fantastic now let's hope
all those technical issues get resolved
otherwise Andromeda might have a rocky
start if you have any questions about
what I played feel free to find me on
Twitter or drop your questions in the
comments below if you love Mass Effect
as much as we do please subscribe
because there will be plenty of videos
on Andromeda in the coming weeks and we
are starting a new show where we try to
make it to the final Citadel DLC with as
few characters as possible as always
thanks for watching